it's amazing to me the number of people
who will want to tell me of a miracle
and their evidence for it is that they
heard that
they heard that a chunk of flying saucer
has been recovered in uruguay they heard
that
there was a machine found impossible to
construct by known human me i say well
where did you hear it say well
you know
on our bell or something like that
this is not evidence of anything except
the foolishness of human beings now if
you have such a machine
we'll talk
you know that's how close in
it has to be because we we live in a
world
mad for weird news
and there's money to be made i mean
think of these people like bud hopkins
and
whitley strieber
and kenneth starr for that matter
in in it is in none of these people's
interest
to come back to the rest of us and say
you know i investigated that flying
saucer or that blow job and
it appears not to have happened it
appears to be a bunch of malarkey this
sells no books this builds no reputation
this advances no agenda no they say well
you know
it looks like this is the real thing and
uh was going to make some real changes
here you have to have your craft
detector in order and if you are content
with rumor then there are enough rumors
around that you need never leave your
armchair you can just enjoy the
weirdness of the world and you don't
have to take drugs and you don't have to
go to bali and you don't have to
get your feet muddy in the rain forest
but none of this is
can be trusted or is uh worthwhile
information mutates it's perverse people
have strange unconscious agendas
so i i will entertain anything
given
that there is evidence
that
will stand the test but rumor doesn't do
it and the other thing is
most people
are incredibly decent
and ha and most people are incredibly
naive
about
how easily some people can be
so
you know here's uh
someone on the telly
in blackened profile
their voice altered by electronic means
and they're saying well i was a nasa
scientist and i was there when the alien
body parts were brought into the freezer
i was under kernels so and so well don't
you ask yourself what why the blackened
screen
why the electronically altered coin i
say well certain agencies of the us
government would hunt me down if i were
to
tell this story
people come on come on
the government if we can handle the
president's blow job we can handle the
knowledge that there are
extraterrestrials interfering with
american politics this idea that we
can't handle it hell there's nothing
else where they spare our feelings
they're perfectly willing to hit you
with the latest tax hike or a
preposterous piece of immigration
legislation or racist malarkey or
homophobic crapola but somehow in this
area of alien contact we're thought to
be so fragile we just can't handle the
news
i i don't bite
uh if somebody has real evidence
we'll take a look but no blackened
screens no anonymity no not for
attribution back channel briefings plea
that's all the sign of
a con job in progress
and then the other thing is
do never be impressed by credentials
of course maybe i say this because i
have practically none
but you know any
weird story which begins like this
former nasa scientist harold schmigley
uh said in santa fe today when i hear
the phrase former nasa scientist i reach
for my revolver
if somebody leads with their credentials
they're conning you
if somebody says human being
david schmigley reports so and so then i
say well that's interesting what does
david have to say but if they
immediately try to snow you like nasa
scientists are supposed to know
something about this or have a better
grip on reality than the rest of us get
real you can't be serious
you know any any stage magician will
tell you scientists are the grist for
the mill the easiest folks to lead
around by the nose there are that's why
well no i don't want to name names or
get into
bashing of particular careers i've
skirted close enough to that already my
point being the truth can defend itself
and if you really want to believe
in the hall of records beneath the
sphinx or the
crop circles or
the area 51 that our government is
trading fetal tissue for high technology
well then hustle your buns down there
and
drink in the bars and buy people drinks
and
and and hear what's really going on
because at the distances we all are from
these phenomena our instruments that
inform us are incredibly
perverse and designed to mislead
befuddle and bamboozle us
and that's one of the things i love
about the psychedelic experience is i've
i sound like one of these mad people you
know the things i say about dmt are
these dead souls is this
extraterrestrial intervention but
i have
a method you can check me
just go smoke dmt now granted it's not
as easy as ordering a double latte but
on the other hand it's certainly a lot
easier than confirming the existence of
alien body parts in some government
vault if you think i'm full of crap
smoke dmt and then come tell me about
how it didn't do anything and or it was
i overrated it tremendously in other
words we have an object that we can
investigate and weird as dmt is we can
investigate it by normal investigative
methods by giving it to people by
interviewing them by building virtual
realities and seeing if they confirm
yeah that's what it looked like to me in
other words strangeness is not in
principle beyond investigation
but the method by which it should be
investigated is no different than the
methods we bring to bear on any other
thing
which puzzles us
and people say well you're not
doing
honor to the terrible trauma that these
victims of alien proctological
examination of had to endure and so
forth and so on will listen
if you if you witness a murder
you have to testify
you have to you have to tell your story
in front of hostile attorneys in front
of a jury in front of a judge you don't
get to say oh it's so horrible i i just
can't i can't give testimony
no
we will compel your testimony
if necessary so the idea that people who
bring extraordinary news to our campfire
should not be grilled
by extraordinary means seems to me
mush-headed and that you will then end
up with unconfirmed rumors hysterias so
forth and so on and then the other thing
is there's money to be made
from these things
you know write a book claiming any damn
thing and you can get a following these
days it is not possible to think up uh
cosmology so absurd
that you can't get at least 500 people
to sell their houses and proclaim you
the avatar and
join up it really isn't and so it's
really a problem for those of us who
really want to know
the real stuff the genuine article and
the and again it's giving weird a bad
name
uh because there is real weird there are
real things dmt weirder than crop
circles weirder than alien intervention
weirder than atlantis weirder than the
hall of records under the sphinx
weirder than all of these fairy tales
are truly real things but
you've got to go out there and kick the
tire and hoot the horn and you can't
rely on on anybody
you know you have to experience it
directly
[Music]
you